[Applause]
hi how are you
good how are you doing good the last
time i saw you i was like attacking you
at an event i was like i love you
i love you so much you know i think it
was me
i think i was attacking you so i feel
like i like full on like accosted you
but so thanks for having me on the show
it's nice to see you
you know we're getting caitlyn ready for
her prom today
and i was just so curious do you
remember your prom of course so i went
to two proms
well actually i went to three but i went
to two um i know
oh i lost oh that's oh that's jim daley
he's gonna kill me
so that's jim daley he was my um i was
in camelot in my
when i was a junior and and he was
lancelot
and i was going to here and um and so i
asked him he was a year younger than me
so i asked him to prom and i drove and
then i
tried to make out with him but he wasn't
very much interested and then this is
chris pujameister
and you'll see that my knee is bent
because i was a little bit taller than
him and i was
super nervous and but he was my like my
first
boyfriend and he was so sweet and he
took me to his senior prom
oh he was like my first like boyfriend
so that was that was the best prom
because he actually kissed me
stories in these pictures but wait did
you ever
like didn't you get a perm at one point
i remember hearing because i got a perm
at one point
and oh yeah because my hair is like
naturally straight oh yeah there we go
there's so many things unfortunate about
this photo the claw bangs the
clear braces that aren't really clear
and a bad perm
you were performing when you had this
perm in fact i think we have a clip of
you which is something we love to do on
this show
let's roll
you it do a thing with your mouth
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i can explain by the way i wasn't i
wasn't balking at the perm i was more
balking i like are freaking out about
the message because that is like in your
face intense
but i love the like you're gonna die
to the jazzy song like they're like
that death and i think
i'm pretty sure in that commercial is my
caboodle remember the caboodle
and they're back i know i'm so i already
got one for my daughter
it's purple so anyway uh that was a psa
for obvious for smoking anti-smoking ad
it was smoking stinks
and so i was you know hired as that was
like my my local claim to fame i
remember i was like i finally made it
when
the drive-through guy at taco bell was
like are you the girl in the smoking
stinks commercial
no you were crocheting right
um and you're a big crocheter yes
i i started crocheting when i was 19 so
i've been doing it for
25 25-20 plus years it's something that
i love to do
i started started off like i had like
lost my voice i had laryngitis and i
started
crocheting just to give myself something
to do and um oh there's my daughter
and uh
for me it's like an emotional thing oh
yeah there's a sweater for her
i've made things that have gotten me
through breakups or deaths or
even like the birth of my daughter like
as i was waiting for her to be born i
was like i don't know what to do i i
feel powerless so i'm gonna make her a
blanket and so you can like
pour your your energy into something and
then it exists forever and it's this
heirloom that could
be passed on and a lot of the things
that i've made
are like little time capsules i have to
tell you too
your crochet is not normal sutton you
could open up
the dopest store and
charge a bundle your work is
extraordinary
thank you would you ever consider
selling them
i it is like my dream i mean it's so
funny i'm like i'm an actress singer
dancer crocheter
i think i would be so happy like just
running like my own etsy store
and just making things i feel like the
people that really know me know me as
like
the crazy crafter i'm really glad to
uncover these personal layers
and celebrate um your final season
younger has been such a beloved show how
does it feel to say goodbye
to this very long chapter it feels very
bittersweet it was seven years of my
life
but i just feel like i hit the jackpot
amazing cast crew
uh just a wonderful place to work a
wonderful place to be
um and it lasted for that that energy
lasted for seven years and
but that final day when they say and
that's a series wrap on younger
you know i um it felt very finite and i
realized oh
i won't be with all of these people you
know this this uh
this combination of people probably will
never be together in this way again
and um and that makes me sad but i feel
so
incredibly grateful and uh i really it
was like the job of a lifetime
well be sure please everybody to check
out her concert
as well uh as the final season of
younger which airs on paramount plus
and hulu it has been so fun thank you
thank you thank you so much and thanks
for having me and thanks for just being
you
because i really i just i admire you so
[Music]
much